president trump's role in subverting our
constitution attempting to block the
peaceful transfer of power and defending
a mob that attacked our capital and law
enforcement has been well-documented and
it's something oddly the president spoke
about in terms of that being one of the
worst is in our democracy and he'll
speak to uh
as i noted a little bit earlier he'll
speak to the historical
significance of january 6 what it means
for the country one year later the
importance of the peaceful transfer of
power which obviously uh the prior
administration and the prior president
weren't a part of uh and uh but i think
there's a larger message here to the
country about who we are and who we need
to be moving forward
does he consider
ex-president trump to be a threat to
democracy
i think he's spoken to this in the past
okay
on the same issue but a little more
broadly
the polls keep showing again and again
that something like 70 percent of trump
voters
think the election
uh was rigged that president mind is not
legitimate and so on
um
is there anything that president biden
feels he should have already done or is
anything he feels he still can do to
actually talk directly to those people
and
try and get you know people's reality to
match a bit more in this country i think
what uh he's going to continue to do is
speak to everyone in the country those
who didn't vote for him those who may
not believe he is the legitimate
president about what he wants to do to
make their lives better and he sees that
as his responsibility as the president
of the united states that's what he will
continue to do
go ahead thanks john happy media um so
senator schumer just said that he and
senator manchin talked numerous times um
during the break mostly on voting rights
but also one built back better and he
also says that the white house will be
having more talks with manchester
participation and cooperation on
buildback better so can i ask did the
president and senator manchin talk at
all over the break
uh we obviously confirmed the
conversation they had uh
two weeks ago i don't have any more
conversations to confirm for you thank
you schumer said about more talks in the
future do you know the next time they'll
talk about it i'm not going to predict
that for you but i can assure you that
the president and members of our senior
team will of course be in touch with a
range of senators who uh care deeply
about moving bill back better forward
can i clarify something on the sure
testing delivery yeah you said the first
deliveries go out later this month then
the website goes up then people can sign
up so probably those tests people can
expect end of this month early february
well i think what i was trying to convey
perhaps not as articulate articulately
as i as i meant to is that we will put
the website up when the tests are
available to be sent right as to not uh
not cause any confusion so i think the
timeline i provided was that for the
first delivery from manufacturers we'll
start later this month and obviously
then we will work to get it out the door
as quickly as possible given that a lot
of experts are saying if overcrowd
follows the surge it did in south africa
it could be peaking here as early as
next week and probably start declining
by the end of the month is there some
concern that these tests are being
provided too late when the worst is
already behind us
well i would say first that there's
unprecedented demand we know that right
now for tests there was in advance of
the holidays for understandable reasons
people wanted to see loved ones
they wanted to ensure they tested before
they saw loved ones and we were not
where we needed to be we're still not uh
what we've done is try to do this as
quickly as possible through an expedited
accelerated contracting process uh to
ensure that tests are available for free
to people across the country as quickly
as possible now at the same time we know
that online and in
retail stores across the country they
are restocking shelves with tests that
is a good thing
we are continuing to open more federal
testing sites as we have done in new
york uh and uh different cities that
have been hardest hit across the country
and we continue to have 20 000 free
sites across the country so we're not
working on one channel uh we're doing it
as quickly as we can to hack to get
these 500 million tests on our hands
doing it through an accelerated
expedited process but we've also taken a
number of additional steps uh to ensure
the federal testing sites just to note
or new jersey dc new york city and
philadelphia those are some of the
places just to give you a sense and
we'll continue to build on that which we
have the capacity to do in the search
that we're seeing now is it fair to say
if those free tests had been made
available earlier before the holidays
before people traveled and more contact
and gatherings occurred
would we not be seeing the same numbers
we're seeing today wouldn't have
prevented some of that spread
i don't know that we can make a
prediction of that it's a good question
to ask the doctors look i would say
though and again reiterate as the
president said before christmas we were
not where we needed to be what he did do
is he quadrupled our testing capacity
from the summer to december he made 50
million tests available at rural health
centers and community health centers in
december to expand that access we opened
these federal testing sites in december
so these were steps we took to as
quickly as possible expedite our
capacity uh even in december as the
demand the unprecedented demand was
rising and doing everything we could at
an accelerated pace of course uh you
know we would have
liked to have more in our hands earlier
um we know those aren't going to hit
families accounts this month right even
though there's relief down the line but
for families who were relying on it
month to month is there any talk of
executive action or anything from the
white house to provide more relief for
them
we are always looking at how we can help
provide relief to american families and
the american people um if
you if buildback better were to pass in
february there is an option of doing
retroactive checks
um but i would note that our objective
is to get this passed uh the president
wants to see the child tax credit
extended go ahead
follow up on testing then if it's going
to take that long i should say in
january sorry in january to do february
if that makes sense yeah go ahead along
those same lines okay for people who who
see those long testing lines yeah more
sites but it's cold now people don't
want to wait in that you swing by cbs
there are no tests
while waiting for all this expanded
capacity what is your advice to people
who may be going back to college and
want to take a test or they want to go
see their grandparents or whatever it
might be if their workplace says
we want you to take a self test before
you walk in
what can people do in the meantime until
that capacity does get built up well uh
it depends on the person so there's a
hard question to answer but i would say
that there are still many doctors
offices that are administering tests if
somebody has health insurance that's
something that you can go do everyone
does not have health insurance there are
community health centers rural health
centers you can go look online and see
if there is one near you and go to that
we have just opened a number of federal
testing sites in new jersey dc new york
city and philadelphia we will continue
to expand those big federal testing
sites and we have 20 000 free sites
across the country different communities
and states are doing taking different
steps some libraries are providing
tests some community buildings are
providing tests it really depends
community to community if tests are
required there's a number of steps and
we're that people can take and we're
working to expand that as quickly as
possible
you would mention rising cases the
president mentioned rising cases a
little while ago every doctor has said
that we've also heard from dr valves you
know the doctors saying that's not the
number to look at we know they're going
to go up but maybe hospitalizations
i think
yeah that's an important point what's
the president's barometer is there one
number
that he
kind of gauges to get an idea of where
the country is right now well what i was
trying to say in response to ed's
question again maybe not as articulate
as i'd like is as dr fauci said one of
the areas that we are concerned about
and focused on is hospital capacity
and that
how that is impacting medical
professionals and the capacity for
hospitals to take people in so we look
at a range of metrics but we certainly
look at that as we see rising cases
it is it is fortunate in many areas that
uh that the vast vast majority if not
all of the people who are going to
hospitals are unvaccinated not in every
community it depends community community
so that's why we are also continuing to
echo and advocate for people to get
vaccinated to get boosted to protect
themselves that's the most important
step they can take but certainly as dr
fauci said we are looking at and
concerned about hospitalizations or
capacity given hospitalizations
back to uh
back to texting how can employers be
obligated to
test unvaccinated workers when there's
such a shortage right now
and what will osha do when it starts
enforcing this rule in a few days when
employers say well sorry we can't comply
because we can't find any tests
well i would first say that two-thirds
of
companies almost two-thirds of companies
have taken steps to put in place uh
either either vaccination requirements
or testing requirements they're all
implementing it in a different way and
the leadership of these companies is
making a decision about what works best
for their workforce giving that option
is something certainly we support
obviously getting vaccinated they're
free across the country available across
the country is also a very easy option
for many people and many companies are
opting to do that
as osha works to implement and work with
companies to do that our objective and
what we're continuing to focus on is
continuing to increase capacity
of free tests that are are targeted more
though at individuals and households
less than companies and obviously to
work there's now nine tests that are
approved to go to market uh that
different companies and different school
districts and others can have direct
contact with so there's a range of ways
to get access to tests and we're working
to increase capacity to make them free
and accessible to households and
individuals across the country
are you saying it's up to workers to
find tests themselves if they must be
tested to go to work rather than their
employer actually i'm saying i think
what i said pretty clearly is that
different companies about 60 of them
have already implemented are
implementing the test or vaccine vaccine
requirements in different ways company
to company employer to employer so and
many of them have done it extremely
successfully including many of the
airlines a number of huge hospital
systems and this has helped make
remember what the objective is here the
objective is to make workplaces safer to
provide more security to people
if you look at the data that just came
out this morning jolts that was a shout
out to bloomberg they'll get that
they'll get that reference um data that
came out today there are still many
people who are fearful about going back
to work that is one of the reasons why
it's important to put in place these
requirements and why employers have
taken the step to provide that certainty
to people in their workplaces as well
i want to ask one more question related
to the workforce
the white house labor task force led by
vice president harris was supposed to
release a report in october about how
the federal government can
boost unionization in this country in a
variety of employers
it's january 4th and that report has not
come out yet
what's going on does the do the
president vice president still care
about this initiative given everything
else that's going on i would say the
president has been an advocate for
collective bargaining rights uh for the
rights of workers for the strong for
strong unions for six five decades of
his career and i think that speaks uh
for itself and the vice president uh
well a little younger not in public
office quite as long but has also been a
strong advocate for uh the rights of
workers um and so i think that speaks
for itself of course this initiative
they initial they put forward um i'm
certain i can check on the status of the
report go ahead thanks jen a couple of
topics if you don't mind um
as you know the anniversary of the
opening of guantanamo bay detention
facilities next week yeah um
the president promised to close it you
reiterated that in february what's
taking so long
um well let me first say that the
national security council continues to
work closely with the departments of
defense state and justice and other
apartments and agencies to do exactly
that i would note and i know this was
put out during a very crazy holiday
period of time but in the president's
statement on the national defense
authorization act for fiscal year 2022
he outlined that section 1032 of the act
continues to bar the use of funds to
transfer guantanamo bay detainees to the
custody or effective control of certain
foreign countries and section 1033 of
the act bars the use of funds to
transfer guantanamo bay detainees into
the united states unless certain
conditions are met and it's a
long-standing position of the executive
branch that those provisions unduly
impair the ability of the executive
branch to determine when and where to
prosecute guantanamo bay detainees in
some circumstances these provisions
could make it difficult to comply with
the final judgment of a court that has
directed the release of a detainee in
addition to limitations in the in
section 1032 of the act constrained the
flexibility of the executive branch with
respect to its engagement and delicate
negotiations with foreign countries over
the potential transfer of detainees
there are only 39 remaining individuals
at guantanamo bay but i just wanted to
highlight that piece that was in the
ndaa uh statement um because we feel
it's obviously creating burden and a
hindrance uh to our progress here so
it's the foreign the transfer to the
foreign countries that's causing delays
essentially oh well i think i listed
three cure
three care clear pieces there and
limitations on how funding can be used
uh on and and how uh uh this uh this
section 1032 also limits at times how an
individual can be released as well as
three uh how we can negotiate and
communicate with foreign countries some
of them have been awaiting trials for
years what what's causing why is that
taking so long
again i i would say this is what we see
as one of the major if not the major
hindrance uh beyond that i would
appoint the department of defense uh but
there are 39 remaining individuals there
and obviously our commitment continues
to be to close guantanamo bay one other
topic the
iranian president said yesterday as the
talks begin in vienna again that
president trump former president trump
should be put on trial for the killing
of general suleimani i wonder if i can
get a reaction to that and whether that
hinders discussions around the iran's
nuclear future
this week
well i would say that i don't have any
direct comment on his comments i would
note that he has his own uh politics and
his own audience that he speaks to
justice
leader another
which resumed on january 3rd there was
modest progress in talks last week and
we hope to build on that this week what
is clear is that if we do not soon reach
an understanding on mutual return to
compliance iran's accelerating nuclear
steps will hollow out the jcpoa so our
priority remains reaching and
implementing a rapid mutual return and i
expect those negotiations will focus on
those topics at hand not comments of any
leaders around the world go ahead
um a couple different topics here as
well um first from the administration's
point of view given what we've learned
from the january 6th select committee um
does it appear the capital right played
some kind of role in an overall
coordinated effort to overturn the
democratic process so
something longer perhaps and more than
just one day
just so i understand your question are
you saying uh
talk a little bit more tell me a little
bit more what you're trying to ask yeah
sure so there's the isolated events of
that day but there's also the
investigation that goes back much
further and spans more time does it
appear that there's that sort of longer
throw there than just what occurred um
on january 6 at the capitol based on
what we know from the select committee
well i'm not going to speak for the
select committee and obviously they will
speak for when the conclusion of their
report will be and what details i i
would note that
we have conveyed our concern in the past
about uh the fact that many republican
members of congress have stood by the
big lie since then uh they were outraged
uh at the time about many of them about
the events uh that happened on january
6th who could not be who was watching
them and since then
they have done nothing to help support
the work of the committee uh to help
argue against the big lie uh and you
know uh that uh sort of um
lack of action in action silence uh you
know is something that is irresponsible
as well
go ahead
oh go ahead sorry another from uh todd
gilman the fellow c
rotation at the dallas morning news um
does the white house have a reaction to
senator cruz saying um president biden
may be impeached if the republicans take
back the house next year specifically
for the border policies
well uh our reaction is maybe senator
cruz can work with us on getting
something done on comprehensive
immigration reform and putting in place
measures that will help
make sure smart security uh is what we
see at the border uh taking a more
humane approach to the border instead of
name calling accusation calling and
making predictions of the future go
ahead thank you jen i have questions
about voting rights and also about
political appointments um on voting
rights
the midterm elections are 10 months away
the surprise the president concerned
that the window is closing to pass
legislation that could have an impact on
how people vote in the midterm elections
i'm not going to make a prediction of
that uh what i will say and what the
president will talk about in his speech
on thursday is also that um
you know people came out the american
public came out in record numbers last
november and participated in our
democracy and we shouldn't underestimate
the role of the
movement and grassroots movement of the
public to have their voices heard
but he absolutely feels that getting
voting rights done is fundamental it's
essential he's going to work in close
lockstep with leader schumer and others
in congress to get this done
but i'm not gonna make a prediction at
this point on the timeline it's
obviously a first priority for them in
the senate
is it a first priority for the president
yes he's working with leader schumer on
it in december he said at south carolina
state university we're going to keep up
the fight until we get it done what does
that look like what does the fight look
like for voting rights for the president
it means getting it passed into law and
signing it into law
what steps is he taking over the next
several weeks to make that happen
well i would first say that the
president has
you can expect to hear more from him
soon and i'm not going to get too far
ahead of that but the president has
taken a range of steps within his own
authority on voting rights whether it is
signing a historic executive order early
in his presidency
supporting the efforts of the department
of justice to increase funding for the
protection of people's fundamental
rights across the country and he also
spoke to
his commitment or openness
to making changes to the process to
protect people's constitutional rights
should that be the point we get to uh
this is obviously going to be front and
center on the senate's agenda when they
return and he's looking forward to being
a part of that on political appointments
the president right now
has has had 266 political appointments
confirmed by the senate that is roughly
on par where president trump was in his
administration this time it's about 100
less than where presidents obama and
presidents bush were at this time in
their first years in office
uh is is that lower number of political
appointments impacting how president
biden can govern and implement his
policies with the executive branch well
so just for the specific numbers and you
gave a number of these but we ended 2020
2021 i should say
with more than 300 of president biden's
nominees for senate confirmed positions
pending confirmation by the senate
approximately half were on the executive
calendar and awaiting a floor vote just
to give you all a sense meaning they
could have moved forward more of these
could have moved forward many of our
nominees have received overwhelming
support and majorities from democrats
and republicans
and the process
for most of the time in the senate was
wound up in
lengthy debates when really there could
have been unanimous consent votes and
moved member of them forward um so
our the president's view is of course
having the people that he has nominated
selected highly qualified individuals
leading departments
running
running different parts of agencies
small large agencies that impact
people's lives across the country is
important and imperative to getting his
agenda done and moving things forward
obviously there are career employees who
insuring uh effectively that agencies
are running but of course he wants to
have his team in place his people
leading these agencies uh to continue to
move his agenda forward does he want the
senate and senate leadership to spend
more time on pushing nominations through
well i think uh
there's a way to move them forward
without consuming uh day hours and hours
and days of floor time we've seen some
agreements and we were
we were encouraged by the agreement that
uh happened right before the the winter
holiday uh to move a number of nominees
forward and we're hopeful we can uh push
more forward in the in the weeks ahead
still 141
positions where there's been no nominee
put forward
why is that
uh again i think uh the president uh one
is eager to have these nominees he has
nominated confirmed that's something the
senate can do congress can do and uh
there are nominations he wants to find
the right person to fill the position go
ahead last one thank you jen and happy
new year happy new year um i have two
questions um one for a colleague who can
be here okay my first one is uh tesla
opened the electric car showroom last
week in xinjiang
uh just days after president biden
signed the uighur uh forced labor
prevention act into law
does the white house have any comment on
and uh will it do more to discourage
american companies from doing business
in xinjiang
sure yes um so i can't speak to the
specific situation of one
company but as a general matter we
believe the private sector should oppose
the prc's human rights abuses and
genocide and xinjiang the international
community including the public and
private sectors cannot look the other
way when it comes to what is taking
place in xinjiang as we've said before
companies that fail to address forced
labor and supply chains and their supply
chains and other human rights abuses
face serious legal reputational and
customer risks not just in the united
states but in europe and around the
world and we've been clear about our
views on the ongoing genocide and crimes
against humanity and jinjong we will
continue to hold the prc accountable i
would also note that we're committed to
taking action to ensure ensure our
supply chains are free from forced labor
including with the bipartisan weaker
force prevention act the president
signed last month and obviously our
continued leadership on the world stage
and one more is on
in light of the
surge of omicron variant in many events
like the two plus two security talks
going virtual uh is the u.s considering
shifting this month's u.s assange summit
to a virtual format will you still do in
person uh i don't have any changes to
the format to preview at this point in
time but we'll check and we'll keep you
all updated thanks so much everyone
you